hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to factorial there may
be an invasion force on the way right
now
to me in this base that wants to eat my
face so my objective now is to figure
out a way that I can get everything I
need quickly
while still maintaining the problem of
Defense okay go alright cool good what
am i holding
ah yeah okay so what I need to do is I
need to stop being a [ __ ] about this
and I need to get the defense up
actually no I don't need to you the
defense of I think the defense is okay
for now so what I need to do is I need
to while I'm doing that I need to start
getting mining rigs going and then the
the not coal ones I'm really exposing
this by putting it all the way out here
I don't know if this is a good idea
alright cool gonna leave them out there
sure it just gives me a little more
flexibility in terms of terrible idea
it's too far out it's no good for
anybody I can use the oh it's time I
goofed it I go if there I go if there I
goofed it Retreat retreat oh no they're
coming oh no oh oh god they're coming Oh
God
kickert that wasn't so bad I'm gonna do
a Flying V actually that was good that
was good that was good right there
flying it's okay oh my god this is much
worse than I figured oh my god they hurt
him so bad it's a lot of damage that's a
lot of damage I'm not to the point where
I can get crafting robots and I will not
be there for quite some time so what I
need to do is I need to overwhelm them
with literal overwhelming firepower that
is quite honestly the only solution that
I have at this moment okay is there any
other research I could do right now
probably this would be a good idea what
No No
oh my god no no no not like this not
like this no no no no no we're gonna
forget I did this why was I wasting so
much time I don't know I don't know all
right let's pretend like nothing
happened because nothing did I should
spend more time reinforcing the defenses
that I have to give them the ammo that
they need as opposed to anything else
and then giving more reinforcements to
the place that needs them okay and then
in the meantime also make more of these
and then some of these and that will
help me get what I need okay good now
we're back on track now we started up
the episode now everything's good let's
see it just make all that a dream oh
it's all just one weird dream where the
enemies we're coming crawling over the
walls and trying to destroy me but I'm
fine I am so good and I was researching
from the get-go hahaha
okay that'll do for now I can't believe
we need to do this we need to put so
much into just making bullets that's all
I have that's all I can do is just make
more
bullets okay good something withheld
something over here and I'm real happy
about that something okay
now that I've got these stirred going
I'm gonna start creating the
infrastructure necessary to get my
mining operation up and running you know
that there that there that there let's
start out with just I'm gonna make more
cuz cuz this is fine everything's fine
but what I want is to for all this to be
automated so that I'm not running back
and forth constantly I'm not constantly
in danger of losing everything of which
I am right now and always that's good
that's a lot of firepower oh yeah
perfect timing oh god I put it all in oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god please please please you're good
you're good you're good you're good baby
oh you beautiful beautiful beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful beautiful
okay nights coming and I don't know if
it gets technically worse at night but I
got a funny feeling it might right this
is great this is going so good okay this
this good okay ooh they're almost animal
okay I need more ammo manufacturing a
lot more what I need is I need to get it
to the point where it's able to repel
basically any attack and nothing will
damage to the point where I need to
actually come help it also very
carefully start the process of
manufacture okay so I got military
that's good because then I can make a
submachine gun and since I'm making
already so much of this good [ __ ] I can
just keep that rolling cuz it may seem
like I'm making a lot of iron I'm not I
I really am NOT because I could be
making so much more and I will have to
make so much more and I will need to
automate so many more systems if I want
this to succeed which I do
death is not preferable at the
time save death for I know the name of
it is death but it's still you know
death not the most preferable thing at
now what I need to do is I need to
reconfigure some of these coal machines
to get coal on this belt here ok this
barely got damaged nice whatever hit it
before ok here comes another wave but I
don't know what's trying to get these
but thankfully it's uh it's not working
ok let's cover up this [ __ ] here they
come
Oh God getting out here ok let's switch
those out oh yes yes baby yes yes ok now
we're doing good now we're doing real
good right now this is just gonna be
iron this is not nearly enough I've got
eight I think one of those is - one of
these maybe it's 2 / I can't remember
what the ratios are right now I'm a
little flustered but I know that this
will be more than enough coal
I'll readjust as needed later but for
now this is gonna do pretty good that's
not a good place for cold oh crap I made
this the wrong way cuz right now it's
this last one on the end is gonna kind
of be left in the lurch but you know
whatever it's it's fine let's go ahead
and reinforce whoa this one down here is
next up on the reinforcements block yeah
they're gonna they're gonna come from
all sides thankfully it seems like I
identified the four quadrants correctly
and I am able to deflect the majority of
their attacks which is what you want to
see that's a beaut that's a beautiful
wall right there that's what they call a
beaut okay I also need to eventually run
this power down dammit of course it
won't match up but that's fine but
that's gonna draw a lot more from my
power my power right now is gonna be an
issue this is gonna consume a lot more
fuel the power requirement is is is
right borderline right there it's
actually not too bad okay and you need
to be walled nope
nope almost ever design this is very
drunk alright cool so yeah this loan
thing ain't gonna cut it I'm gonna have
to reroute all all of this eventually
and then move this over when I get a
chance it doesn't seem like anything is
attacking from that direction which is
good but for the time being just gonna
leave that where it lies so now what we
need to do is just get these yeah it
should just do cold I'll do electric on
the a of the outside now that's gonna
drain my power a bit that's definitely
gonna be a power problem boom alright
now now this is where I need people to
definitely not criticize anything I'm
doing because frankly I don't really
know I'm just like I know this is not
gonna be pretty
I what I'm about to do here don't judge
me
it's it's just I need to get operations
up period and that's the end of the
story and that's as far as I'm gonna
talk about that okay thankfully I don't
think they're gonna attack my pump at
all but they're definitely gonna be
pissed off at this thing but I need to
because I have to have more power let me
just go ahead and set up something here
for that it's it's like this just gonna
have to do like there's no other way
around it I can't do what I need to do
and make that work prettily I have a
limited amount of space and I got a
limited amount of time and this those
four were apparently more than enough
for these dudes I cool how did you get
there
whoa whoa whoa well I was looking away
for like two seconds what happened what
the hell happened air attack what
happened why do they want this side so
badly they just really really want this
side I don't understand it I don't care
for it none I don't want it none that
ain't cool okay that not cool alright
I'm just gonna build a great wall here
nice cool awesome
SiC I'm gonna just bub we're just gonna
look that's how that's gonna be a well
no that's not how that's gonna be
because I'm double layering it this is
how this is gonna be now and then I'm
gonna dull so make a wall up to that
North I think I can actually reach it
and eventually I'm gonna have to move it
because you're sitting on my copper or
whatever cool I need these to be bullets
please thank you okay so this is now an
unlimited source while not unlimited but
it's it's currently as it stands a
pretty darn big source of what I need so
I can take these now cuz they don't do
me any good down here and I'll leave
these for now to finish out what they
were doing
you need copper you need some more belts
and you need something to pull them out
of said belts I need to make more of
these it's it's a never-ending cycle
this game it's never-ending it's like
always and forever alright so and then
this one it can go feed other things
that aren't bullets great yearning need
for even more bullets now I'm gonna set
up something for I'm gonna make a couple
splitters and then I'm gonna change up
this so that I can have these feeding to
us a row of Urban's that I can take from
about let's let's call it here it's
about two per I'll take half of it for
now oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god no no
no no no no no no no no no no no Jesus
they come from all directions all at
once every of the Tufts straggler
someday soon these are gonna be full up
all the time but for its dumb why was I
dumb I don't know but for now it's gonna
be okay okay who got the splitter right
here more mwah oh my god oh my god
they're out of ammo oh my god Phil Phil
Phil Phil shoot
mmmmmm do not play with me right now do
not play with me right now
do not mess with me I do not like that I
do not consent to that I am NOT about
that you all need to stop you need to
stay you have to stop I'm gonna have to
go kill things get out of my face
I'm gonna have to go kill things soon
it's because there's too many of those
causing problems for me let's keep
moving on this can't let it go slow and
let it die down I'm gonna stick to just
coal right now cuz I don't have time to
make fancier stuff us so I'm just gonna
build this and then manually put it all
in and then this coal line is gonna come
down here
that way it'll fill in on one side and
then I can fill in please tell me I'm
handling that oh my god
it's never-ending these [ __ ] are
never-ending they are okay so I need
more inserters I mean technically I
could do burners for now I can always
upgrade them later and then up up round
down connect got it boom and I need to
be researching something oh yes I forgot
I can upgrade them hundred mm that's
great I need that I need the turret
damaged I need it so badly ah but it's
so many resources it's so many sciences
holy crap alright if you could not be
over here you could be you know anywhere
but there that'd be wonderful Thanks
it really is never-ending here comes
another way from the north side okay
let's put just like some down here
please tell me that was handled over
there I don't hear firing which I'm
assuming means they're dead it could
mean many things
hopefully that they're dead let's do
burner inserters I'm very close to wall
security you know what honestly um I
just also have these making bullets
because I don't think I can pass
we have enough bullets let's just make
it here I'm not too thrilled about it
but I don't have space to really think
about things
this is gonna be spaghetti okay
bullets are a go wall is almost to go
all right you're starting to get uppity
because you're starting to get alone up
here don't like that the good news is
seems like I have officially shut down
one quadrant whoa we're gonna have to
wall manufacturers and then the rest is
just gonna get dumped
whatever overflows yeah I am doing so
good I'm a champion here this is a
delight I think I can get rid of this
because I have enough firearm
manufacturer up north so that's good god
I feel like I haven't even had a second
to breathe till he even talked to you
guys about what's happening so if you've
been lost if you've been confused it's
fine okay so I'm gonna make this last
one actually not a bullet machine I'm
gonna make it a gear machine and it's
going to toss directly and do another
assembler that is going to make science
I'm gonna put a box with copper going in
and then a box for science coming out
it's not pretty but it'll do okay so
it's not gonna be a lot of science but
hey at this point I'll take it all right
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna start
making my wall here actually I can just
go ahead and start making it here too so
my coastal wall I don't need to be too
ambitious at first
oh no no no no no oh my god oh my god oh
my god no no no no no no no no no no no
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
no it's fine just respawn these [ __ ]
don't ask those [ __ ] those [ __ ]
those [ __ ] thank you for that thank
you really appreciate that the one time
this bottom left corner hasn't had none
has not had none has had none and then
the moment I step over there to start
building my wall you guys start stepping
out oh time to go see the neighborhood
oh we gotta go check on how the new guys
doing Obie's friendly oh my god no no I
don't like you going for that little gap
that's not cool that's what you call not
cool holy crap they're just going for
the extremities
where are they going for the extremities
I have enough firepower of the know
these guys are being dicks oh they
waited oh they waited they planned that
oh they planned that okay
all right you know what fine okay you
can broke one of them can you suck all
right fine fine that's fine
I am totally 100% fine with that this is
how you want to play the game I am more
than happy to oblige
I will oblige you so hard you're gonna
see just how far you will be obliged try
me you sad sacks of poopie where did you
come from
hello where'd you come from God just I'm
just my entire life is of running back
and forth my entire existence is just
trying to hold this [ __ ] together though
here they come speaking of trying to
hold this [ __ ] together
there you go there you go that's more
like it that's more like it
can't you [ __ ] hold your anvil for
one I turn my back for one second on you
douches and you just run out of ammo
it's so weird how do you do that you
need call you all need coal oh no no no
no no no no no no ok that's that's
handleable so that's what we've been
handling it seems like a lot and it
probably is but is handleable God
everything is just to the
military-industrial complex on this
place do everything is about strength if
I don't have strength I have nothing I
am nothing I'm less than nothing
get the firearm magazines firearm eggs I
have to complete this wall I have to but
I can't I can't complete it and then
leave it defenseless so I have to
complete it and then immediately man it
with guns because if I don't and
everything that's gonna go to [ __ ]
please give me more guns okay that's
good guns make sure they're in the
corners right bam bam bam five there
there and there
I'm just gonna manually do this oh here
they frickin come oh my god I see them
on the radar lick see and zoom doom is
coming here oh my god they are
assembling oh my god I'm just looking at
them on the radar and I am NOT happy
with that I'm not happy I'm not happy at
all that should be illegal but the wall
is doing better okay and hopefully
there'll be more bullets and then more
turrets and then oh good all good baby
all good all good all good all good all
good I don't I only have one thing
making turrets I could make more turrets
I should be making things why am I not
making things all the time no
everything's fine
oh here they come
nice that was good and then these guys
cut all [ __ ] you know what this let's
just oh oh my goodness gravy oh my
goodness oh my goodness oh my goodness
oh my goodness oh we're all out of
bullets oh my god we're all out of
bullets please no please no please no
they were so cool why were you out of
bullets
no no no no no this cannot be again I
mean you blew one of them
you blew one of them up oh no oh no how
do I not have enough how how do I not
have enough bullets how can I possibly
not have enough bullets how's that
possible
I have so many bullets the entirety of
my resources are dedicated to crafting
bullets that's all I do this is
everything that I am is making bullets
oh my god repairing takes so much time
to do and I'm not making bullets
apparently that's what I should be doing
always this world will not destroy me I
will make this world my [ __ ] it will
not make me it's [ __ ] not it [ __ ]
I [ __ ] it it is the [ __ ] of me know
who's fighting down there
who's fighting down there someone's
fighting down south why who why are they
winning
they better be winning they won there's
so many that are coming from the south
there's just so many I can't fathom how
many are coming from the south it's
dumbfounding I need this upgrade because
if I done all right like what'll I do
what do I do if I don't get this upgrade
what I have nothing I have absolutely
nothing okay
oh they're coming from there oh well
that's okay because kind of the circuit
route makes them not so dangerous I
can't believe these have held that for
as long as I have oh that's not gonna
hold that's not gonna hold that there's
no way oh there's no way that's gonna
that's not gonna hold oh my god
no oh no no no I literally just said I
couldn't believe it was holding why are
these backing up I why are they backing
up they shouldn't be backing up why
would they be backing up they don't need
to be backing up stop backing up go
forward you don't need to back up why
was the boys backing up
why back up go forward you go forward
that's how you do you take it you go
forward I got to put oh God before they
come again they're gonna come they're
gonna come for me
they're coming for me Oh God the
defenses are all down Oh God
like this please not like this this
impregnable defense oh god I wish I
could just I wish I could just replace
it so much for repair it I just need to
close up my keep that's all I have to do
I just have to close it up get all of it
closed because if I can get it closed I
I can get a head on the ammo I know that
I can cuz apparently these are making
more ammo than it could hold but I
wasn't feeding it enough iron to do so
so I know I can get enough ammo I just
need to close it okay I'm gonna start on
this northern part here because it
seemed mmm that's a small one relatively
small they don't even get close
that is not enough ammo by the way that
it's not enough I am aware of that fact
that is a fact
absolutely not enough however I don't
care at this moment could not care less
okay if it's almost enclosed the keep is
almost freakin enclosed I need more on
these corners that's what I'm realizing
the more defense on the corners that's
what this is now where the brunt of it
is gonna be so I can actually take some
of the guns from here
oh no that's a big and get off get off
get off get off get off get off get off
I can actually take some of the guns off
of here and I can bring them up okay so
then I can put I can put these together
like this just to give it a little more
beef whoo let me go reinforce this wall
here I think I might actually be doing
it my dudes I might actually be doing it
until I run out of iron here and then I
die a horrible death but until that time
comes I might actually be doing it might
actually be doing it very not far away
from the truth you know what I mean okay
they're assembling down there
interesting interesting interesting
choice interesting choice that's a lot
of them has a lot I will shoot you or
come after me come after me come out hit
me not my wall hit me yes stupid are you
stupid
apparently you're dumb okay that I can
connect these I totally can connect
these okay okay these are almost out of
bullets bullets boats bullets bullets
bullets bullets bullets bullets bullets
bullets bullets bullets gonna bullet I
can make bullets I can make bullets we
get the science going I am less than
halfway to the projectile why although I
all hear you suck you suck oh you suck
okay we're so close well we gotta do the
same thing here
oh my god the keep isn't closed oh the
Cape is a glows guys the keep isn't
closed it's not gonna stay that way if I
don't maintain this but holy crap holy
crap holy crap holy crap oh my god I
never in a million years thought I would
even get to this point and I'm not safe
I get I am not safe that nothing is safe
at this moment nothing at all
absolutely dick and diddly is safe
however holy crap oh my god keep closed
I gotta put more ore here okay so
they're they're kind of congregating
over in these areas which is unfortunate
but I can deal with it
okay wowie wow wow wow okay so now I
just have to fill everything to the brim
with goodies with goody goody gumdrops
this is what I'm everything everything
is dedicated to this cause there is no
other cause besides war on this planet
this is 40k planet I am fighting
tyranids this is everything that could
possibly go wrong in this world okay
they're coming over there I want to see
them all work beautiful beautiful you
all they don't even touch the wall oh my
god this is so stressful all right guys
it's a tiny base it is my tiny corner of
the world and there's so much more that
I have to do in the manufacturing
Department in terms of modifying and
improving and making sure everything is
good like I have not gotten anywhere in
terms of technological improvement but
my goodness gracious I got here and I
did not think that would be possible I
don't know if the whole game is gonna be
such a panic but I've got a foothold
I've got a foothold
and I've got redundancies and I've got a
system to fuel the war machine and
that's more than I can say that I had
when I started eventually I will venture
out and I will try to kill but these
bases are so big and I really have no
idea how I'm gonna handle it
so we'll cross that bridge when we get
there so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know if you want more of
this down in the comments below let me
know if you're enjoying it too and as
always I'll see you in the next video
[Music]